on the mercedes-benz van phone line is
none other than uh
john lovitz whose two b's tales of a
fifth grade robin hood is available
right now on to be back here in the rich
housing how are you doing john
great how are you nice to talk to you
again yes nice to talk with you again um
so uh first things first uh john is i
i'd love to you know uh talk with you
about your project and we will but i did
want to bring up um norm mcdonald first
if you don't mind and your thoughts on
on somebody who i'm sure you've known
for quite some time
well i yeah i didn't know he was sick at
all it's sad he was a uh
you know great comedian and uh very very
very funny very talented
i when i started doing stand-up i used
to uh
i would host shows for snl like for five
minutes with
victoria jackson and kevin nealon and
and uh and then later on i you know i
got better and better and then i started
opening
as an opener for norm
and then we would co-headline
about for about a year i did that and
then i started headlining on my own
but he was always very very funny nice
guy and uh
it's sad you know he was a son and
i out when his son was little i feel
very bad for his son
but i had no idea that he was a
zero idea that he was sick i mean i
don't i don't know anyone that knew
the guys at community i talked to they
were closer to him than me they didn't
know and so
i mean what would you say because i've
gone down um what we all have like a
youtube wormhole on all of norm's bits
and moments and
i mean what would you say because the
thing that everybody keeps talking about
is how fearless he was and his
commitment and things like that do you
got a good story about any of that
either from saturday night live and
obviously well
yeah i you know he was you know really
smart you know he was like a math genius
and he was extremely bright
so one time we were doing a show in um
in milwaukee mississippi and i i'm not
i'm not like him at all except if you if
you say to me like you can't say that or
talk about a certain thing or don't say
that i'm like well now i have to it's
just kind of your instinct
to bug people you know right don't do
that it really bothers me and then
you're kind of a jerk not like oh you
mean like this
so
so we were doing a show and
i opened for him about i did about i
guess 15 minutes or 20 then he headlined
but it was for um
it was for a um
what do you call it
um
when they comp the audience you know
big gamblers i forget the word yeah so
it wasn't people paying tickets but
anyway they did it we did it so he's
doing the show and he's you know he's
very funny but he's dirty so so also
someone yells out well we don't like
that kind of talk
so there's about i don't know 400 people
there and he was well how many of you
don't like that kind of talk
you know and it was like the whole
practically the whole room here well how
many of you don't mind and it was like
20 people
just or 10 people he goes well i i hate
to disappoint that
those 10 people because the rest of you
don't like it and then he just got
dirtier
i'm just like crying laughing you know
because
the ice wasn't even laughing but he just
you know
and that that was
you know that was a typical him yes
fearless commitment no doubt about that
and just a couple more on this and then
we'll we'll we'll move on uh he did that
when he arrested bob sage yeah i was
going to bring that one up
they edited it kind of screwy way
so you think of the point of the roast
they go you know be funny but like be
dirty right
so then he everyone's doing that
including me and then he gets up
and it's just telling the worst corniest
jokes and that cuz just horrible jokes
and then just going on and on so the
audience is just staring at him they
weren't laughing right yeah and i
realized it was the same thing he did in
mississippi he's just doing it to bug
him
so i'm like crying laughing because he
because he's eating it on purpose you
know what i mean he's just bombing on
purpose but it was on purpose you know
the jokes were horrible and i realized
they don't that's the joke but of course
they don't get it because the jokes
aren't good so of course they're not
laughing
but i know what he's doing so i was like
crying laughing because i knew he was
doing it just to bug him and do the
opposite and you see bob sagas because
bob knows that's what he's doing yeah
he's just going doing the opposite of
what they said you're supposed to do
be dirty and funny as honestly clean and
tell horrible jokes yeah i remember the
joke was like your face looks like uh
cauliflower you know like you look so
ugly you look like your face looks like
cauliflower and then people would laugh
and bob was laughing his dark because
yeah like a colleague
afterwards but i was there on stage
they talked to me crying laughing and
when i was some joking but i was like
like pounding cuz i just laughed more
and more because he was just
he was purposely you know trying to just
tell these horribly corny jokes
and and and bob knew what he was doing
you know well honestly just they were
just staring at him like what is this
well i mean i was there i'm like dying
laughing you know yeah i was there for
the uh espy awards uh when he hosted and
um a lot of espn executives were white
knuckling his
his monologue the entire time
and when he told the joke about charles
woodson winning the heisman trophy and
no one's going to take it away from him
as the first defensive player unless he
pauses and well unless you you kill your
wife and a waiter and the whole place
just like you've got to be kidding me i
mean that was wild to say the least john
lovitz did they laugh well there was a
lot of i think sort of woe and nervous
laughter and then cutting away to
athletes who were just like shaking
their heads like they didn't know what
to do they had no idea what to do with
their faces you know at that time right
it's like that then he's he you know
you take a big risk when you do that i
mean he did that at the casino we were
banned for i couldn't work there for
five years really
are you serious
he got banned from that casino in biloxi
mississippi
he was gambling and he got caught
counting cards
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh there's that too
oh i mean
so the combo
[Music]
john lovitz here uh on the rich eisen
show how did you get uh to snl john back
in the day how did you get there um
basically well
basically i did plays in high school and
drama is uc irvine
and then i did the class for camera and
i went to new york for years to get
anywhere so i started came back to l.a
when i was 25 and started
class at the growling theater the improv
group and i figured i'd work my way up
to classes and my goal is to get in the
company and get seen and get work but i
never thought i'd be on saturday night
live
and they put the growlings on the
tonight show and that got me an agent
and said mike i understand i'm going to
submit you for signing live ago you're
because i yeah i go yeah right now i'm
serious i go why don't i land on pluto
why don't i do that
it was just out there and then i got him
but he got me auditions and i got a move
with charles grodin oh god bless his
soul and he recommended me to lauren
on his own and lorraine newman who was
an original cast was in the ground she
saw me to play
in the summer of 84 and she recommended
me and i always say those two really got
me the job but just kept auditioning and
then the tonight show
it's crazy that uh jim jim mccauley was
the producer and his nature of all the
comic uh
segments and jim mccauley is the one
that really discovered all these you
know comics like jim carrey and roseanne
barr and gary shanley and
bill maher and on me and gave them their
big break on the tonight show you know
and and he would prepare their sets and
work with him go okay you're ready you
know it was jim mccauley so he came to
the growling theater and next thing i
know i'm on the tonight show doing my
liar character
and i couldn't believe it and but that
got me the agent mike and then
just kept auditioning and but when i met
with lauren i i i met with al i met al
franken and um
tom davis they were producing the show
that year
and then i met with lauren
and he was holiday ago 28. he was oh
billy murray was 28. so i thought is he
telling me i had the job and and
years later he goes yeah that
didn't you know i go i thought i thought
so when you said that
but jim mccauley this is how crazy it is
yeah they hired a guy at nbc fred
weissman to look for people for saturn
live in los angeles fred weissman was i
said how did you hear me go
he was well you know they hired me
because i was a dentist
so i didn't know anything and they gave
him that job so i went to jim mccauley
and fred was a great guy because i went
to jim mccauley and i go who's good you
know
and jim said john lovetts is the best
sketch comedian in los angeles i go he
said that
because yeah i go oh my god because to
me
you know a phil hartman and tim stack
were the guys i looked up to at the
groundlings they've been there for years
i go they're the knee they're the best
guys i've seen you know
so i i just couldn't believe when i got
the show i couldn't believe it how good
was phil hartman man i mean just well
phil was the best you know he was like
my i
because of him i got to be in this play
at the groundlings i understudied the
part so i was so grateful and then that
got me into the company so
he became like he was nine years older
than me so he's like my big brother and
i just
idolized him you know and he was the
nicest guy in the world and
he was a real genius and he could just
i always said the only two comics i know
that could change their face
without any makeup was him and
jim carrey and they could look like the
character they were playing but with no
makeup their face is just so
malleable and
i i could do that in a billion years and
they were if they could do it you know
and that's
crazy talent and then he could just do
anything and he believe in his office
and i go what are you doing is i'm
reading a magazine about fly fishing and
then
three weeks later i i'd come by his
office well he was next door to me and
yes no and like what are you doing he's
all making flies you know and like
expertly making them like
you just read a magazine about it now
you're like making them perfect
but he would just throw himself into
something
and become that like he
he learned how to fly and got and so i
flew with him
i don't know maybe three or four times
but he would become a character like it
was like flying with a pilot from united
airlines like that yeah and he would
talk like that yeah this is uh
but he would just i'd be laughing i
could jesus
i got to tell you i mean like of all his
characters
of course the only guy
that would be like you know saturday
live you know with comedians in a group
or the groundlings or news radio and
he's the only guy that ever he got never
gotten fights anybody got along with
everybody well i mean just
i don't know what characters i would
even say were his best obviously sinatra
and ed mcmahon and then of course he did
bill clinton but uh the unfrozen caveman
lawyer is one of my favorite things i
could remember and then well jack handy
who'd write you know deep thoughts by
jack candy right jack wrote that
phil was also the only guy in the show
we're all trying to get in the show as
much as we could and he would he would
complain i meant too much
[Laughter]
intense sketches well it was too much
you know
well i mean what about really hard you
know but they just like he could play
anything one of my favorite uh
characters though to be honest with you
is when
uh kevin nealon would be tarzan you were
tanto and he was frankenstein and he
would just mumble you know i mean
that was
johnny wrote that they're making a
documentary now called jim wrote that
okay and and and and we would never get
many laughs i say jim why don't we keep
doing this because it's funny to go
well i go
you have an arrow i go phil's funny
that's how i felt i go he's funny you
know but i go but it's not
though they love it at home but the
audience would be barely laughing you
know
but phil would do it and i would just be
crying laughing you know inside my head
he was so funny i mean the season's
greeting were you
where the three of you were were giving
a season's greeting about christmas and
it like a television telethon or just
like hey from a local news here's tonto
tarzan
by the way i think kevin is very funny
me too within that sketch you too john
you know we were kevin and i were
basically
doing the same thing
but jim goes it's guys that don't use
you know articles don't say gun and you
know you go home now me not have good
time
so it was like guys like that and then
but the gym wrote a sketch it was oh mel
gibson
no one was uh yeah it was mel gibson was
frankenstein's evil brother
and but he was really sick hello
brother you know and then he looked like
frankenstein but when was a
tarzan was having an affair with jane
and
no frankenstein was having an affair
with jane so i have to go tell tarzan
you know that was a that was a really
good one yeah phil was
hysterical one time we were it was
tarzan tano and frankenstein yeah on the
pat stevens show which was a
a character nora dun did she's like the
head of a modeling agency not the
brightest woman
the character pat stevens so
we're so she's interviewing tarzan
tonto and frankenstein so the four of us
are out there and all of a sudden phil
starts he start he just laughed out of
the blue
and then he stopped
and then about 10 seconds later he just
lost it it was just laughing
hysterically
and nothing had happened
and and we're just looking at like what
is he doing so it's infectious so then
we start laughing and i'm like putting
my face in my head you know my arm and
i'm going geez this is live television
like what are you doing
so afterwards
the sketch i said phil i go what
happened
because nothing had happened
and he goes well i was just sitting
there
thinking about the sketch and it just
struck me so funny so i just laughed
because it was so ridiculous
and then i stopped and then i started
thinking about what i must have looked
like to people at home watching the show
seeing frankenstein laugh like that
john lovetts here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about your show uh on two
details of a fifth grade robin hood uh
what do you want folks
to know about it john well i mean it was
a fun movie to do i i uh and the movies
for kids it's on to be which is a a
streaming a new streaming division from
fox
and it's free they have like 35 000
titles and movies and original content
and uh the movie i did is about it um as
this kid goes to elementary school it's
an underfunded school and i play the in
the principles away and i play the evil
vice principal who's taking money from
the fundraisers and
and i'm just
trying i'm gonna go i'm just trying to
get on the board of supervisors
basically i just want to swindle every
school that i can
sell all the supplies and desks and book
everything just get money
so and and this guy foiled foils the
plot you know it's like
robin hood he's trying to you know get
the money from me and the rich people
and give it to the kids
so he's a very clever kid so it was fun
to do but i i've i've never played a
part in the movie where i'm like a
really the bad guy
and um so i i wanted to do it you know
okay so i did well i i can't
my wife and i are always looking for
stuff to show our kids and watch with
our kids so
we're in we're totally interested
very young kids they were like yeah it's
a family thing for young kids fantastic
and it's called tales of a fifth grade
robin hood the movie is available right
now on tubey
john lovitz uh let's do more of this i i
could literally talk to you for a very
long time for hours and months all right
rich well let me know i'll do it
whenever you want i'm shaking on your
show absolutely thanks jonathan i'm not
just saying that no no i i i i've heard
you on other shows and i've heard you uh
leave other shows and not say that to
the host so i truly believe you john i
totally believe that's the ticket that's
i totally guess well they never said i
could talk to you forever and love to
have you back either okay and i meant it
so let's do it we'll chat soon john
thanks again john take care that's john
lovitz everybody at realjohnlovitz on
twitter at john underscore lovitz
on instagram i could hear those stories
for oh yeah me too
unfrozen caveman lawyer is my favorite
i'm just a caveman
what a voice he had
he had the great voice i'm just a
caveman i don't know
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here